the market for sports trading cards is
booming
sports is a lot of people's escape
why not invest in a player as opposed to
investing in a stock the top 25 most
expensive cards in history were sold in
the last two years
including an onus wagner card sold for
over 6.6 million dollars a lot of us
been holding on these guys for 30 years
hoping someday that they'd be worth
something hoping someday i could say i
told you so big time investors like
hedge funds are also in on it they've
begun buying trading cards as
alternatives to equities it's culture as
an asset it's nostalgia as an asset
so how do trading cards balloon into a
multi-billion dollar industry and why
are both everyday people and big name
investors turning to trading cards as
investment assets
this is niche markets a series that
examines small lesser-known markets that
despite their size punch well above
their weight
in front of us we have a bunch of cards
one of them being as early as the 1934 a
famous card called the gowdy all the way
down to hoeness wagner and joe dimaggio
we believe that they are authentic we'll
send them in to get graded to verify a
card's authenticity and determine how
much it's worth today's card owners rely
on a practice known as grading
collectors send their raw or ungraded
cards to grading agencies where their
cards will be examined and assigned a
one through ten grade card scores are
based on four different factors
centering
corners
edges and surface
so we ended up getting them all graded
they all came back real
one is the lowest grade you can receive
that is as terrible as it comes um
there's a crease right down the entire
middle of it corners are all paled up
edges are all dinged up this card is
probably around 100 to 200 card raw but
once you get it graded it's real it's
authenticated it's now a one we now know
the value of it's around 800 to a
thousand dollars to know that its value
is worth x or y because of its grade is
what really turned this hobby into
what it is now as a stock market in the
past buyers had to take a seller's word
on the legitimacy of a card's condition
but today thanks to grading companies
like psa beckett and sgc acting as
neutral arbiters of quality a card's
price is much easier to verify
one of the things that my mom always
said that i couldn't really have an
answer for was that card's not worth
twenty dollars until you get someone to
give twenty dollars for it and that's no
longer true
bert duveaux jesse duveau and jeffrey
ferraro are the owners of fresh pulls a
trading card shop located in the
outskirts of boston
three friends opened the store in may
after making a small fortune auctioning
cards online we did two million dollars
in sales we should break the three
million dollar mark within the next
month by the end of september
since the trio started their business in
march of 2020 they've all left their
jobs in the hospitality industry and
seen their material circumstances
transformed i used to work 70 hours a
week in a kitchen and be absolutely
miserable now i can work 150 hours here
and it doesn't seem like 150 hours
fresh pulls his story is but one example
of card owners striking it rich in
today's market since the pandemic began
reports of former hobbyists digging up
their old collections and discovering a
windfall have not been uncommon
sports cards have existed since the
early 1900s but in the 1980s and 1990s
prices for newer cards cratered after
manufacturers flooded the market ken
griffey jr is his rookie card is known
for being one of the most mass-produced
cards and it's just not valuable
the pandemic also triggered a string of
deals and acquisitions that have shaken
up the industry
earlier this year the investment firm
the churning group along with
celebrities like mark cuban and kevin
durant invested 40 million dollars in
one of the industry's best-known auction
houses golden auctions this july golden
was acquired by the investment group
collectors holdings it's an exciting
time for everybody here at golden it's
an exciting time for the industry as a
whole also in july blackstone acquired a
majority stake in the grading company
certified collectibles group which
values cgc at more than 500 million
dollars
these people have people to tell them
where to invest their money they're not
telling them to invest billions of
dollars into the card market for it to
just collapse
right now i'm holding two of my most
favorite cards they both are a 1997 kobe
bryant precious metal gems the red
version there are a hundred of them in
the world this is a psa five and a half
this one's a psa four and a half this
card right here i bought for thirteen
thousand dollars is probably worth
between a hundred and sixty and two
hundred thousand dollars leor avidar was
an avid card collector when he was
younger especially for kobe bryant cards
but he didn't return to the hobby until
2016. i went on ebay
and the first box of cards that i went
and and looked for was the ex-2000 i had
never gotten that kobe bryant green card
that i was
that i really wanted when i was young
and i saw that there were different
price points like some were selling for
thirty dollars there was one that was
selling for three thousand dollars and i
was like why is this why is one thirty
and wise one three thousand dollars
avidar who has a background in finance
saw opportunity in the inefficient way
in which pricing was determined and i
remember seeing that the probability the
expected value was positive meaning if i
kept buying the boxes and
probabilistically i will get the kobe
bryant card and then i sell it on ebay
i'll make 10 to twenty dollars a box
after five years of buying and selling
cards avidar turned his passion into a
business
in march of 2020 avidar launched alt
which aims to be a sort of coinbase for
collectibles where users can buy and
sell cards just like more conventional
assets alt brands itself as a modern
financial institution that allows people
to invest in things they're passionate
about just like stocks when you log into
alt it feels a lot like coinbase or
robinhood or fidelity in real time you
can actually see how much your portfolio
is worth similar to how zillow uses its
zestimate figure to track home prices
all created the alt value to track card
prices the number one question when
people start getting into cards is how
much how much are my cards worth the
whole point of the alt value is to give
people confidence around the values and
just increase some of the transparency
that exists in the ecosystem but just
hasn't been prod brought out and
democratized
on the internet so far alt is just one
of a new crop of digital services
catering to the rapidly growing trading
card market
collectible and dibs allow users to buy
and trade fractional shares of cards
star stock brands itself as a stock
market for sports cards
all right guys good luck good luck good
luck good luck fresh poles has made most
of its money by hosting a relatively new
type of online auction called case
breaking patriot julian edelman and a
kid reporter nothing there to start case
breaking is essentially gambling on
unboxing videos a break involves groups
of collectors co-investing in a case
inside of which are packs of cards and
then watching a live stream of the
unboxing peyton my boy man rookie nice
card that's how we start off first box
mojo baby so there's a two thousand
dollar box of nba basketball ten of us
spend two hundred dollars and we each
get three random teams so let's say you
have the celtics the knicks and the
wizards i open up the box every celtics
nixon wizards cards in that entire box
all goes to you days later collectors
received the cards they won in the mail
two packs left two packs left one things
that people asked us at first like why
would somebody pay you to open their
cards
and it's not that they're paying us to
open the cards they're having an
experience like if you take the pack
home and open it by yourself in your
bedroom you're alone like when you do it
with us you're in a room full of friends
in the grand scheme of things is a
casino you're coming in here and
gambling
most of the people in this world love
sports and
fantasy football and gambling like those
are the things that aren't going
anywhere joshua kelly rookie too bad
that wasn't a damn herby i don't see the
card marker going anywhere for a long
long time then jefferson bad
card
purple stars
[Music]